[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bill shaiken is a national baseball
writer for the la times and i saw the
headline
of his column most recent column dodgers
failed world series bid cost them money
and trust now the bill comes due and i
liken this to christmas time when you
spend all that money on all those gifts
and then you get the credit card bill at
the end of the month you're going oh my
god
bill shaiken joining us now bill uh
would you say that's an apt uh analogy
of what's going on here with the dodgers
as they head into the offseason
i think pretty much with the exception
of the coal that the dodgers fans are
going to find in their stocking this
year because he was ready for a
back-to-back championship and the
dodgers unfortunately for the fans did
not even get back to the world series
if you were going to pinpoint one thing
and say this is the reason why the
dodgers aren't playing in the world
series what would you what would you say
well if you look at a team that when we
got to spring training everybody said
what are you gonna do with all these
starting pictures there's eight starting
pictures here and i know the cliche is
you can never have enough pitching and
everybody kind of rolls their eyes
because everybody does that at cliches
but in this case turned out to be true
because by the time the dodgers got to
the playoffs they had three starting
pitchers and by the time they played the
last game of the nlcs they had two
healthy starting pitchers and some of
that is
health of course some of it is you know
trevor bauer sexual assault
investigation that's left him
unavailable to the dodgers for half the
year uh and some of it is just guys not
developing and as it turns out
what the dodgers ownership had done and
to their credit was to say look we won
the division seven straight years in a
row we haven't won the world series
we've prioritized our player development
we don't want to trade our elite
prospects
but we have won the world series
so they went out and got mookie bets and
under andrew friedman the dodgers had
never paid anybody more than a hundred
million dollars by the time mookie betts
is done with the dodgers they're in for
close to 400 million dollars yay the
dodgers won the world series last year
that worked out great they saw a window
again this year because of all the
players on expiring contracts clayton
kershaw
corey seeger kenley janssen said you
know what
um let's try again and trevor bauer was
the guy they chose it didn't work out
obviously but
now all the prospects that they traded
the ones that they used to say we don't
trade our top prospects
they're in boston for the bets trade
when
bower was sidelined because of the mlb
and police investigations the dodgers
went out and got max scherzer and trey
turner and that was great of course it's
another all-in move but now scherz is a
free agent and the two top prospects the
dodgers had to give up to get scherzer
and trey turner they're in washington
they're not here dave roberts getting
any heat
when does a manager not get heat after
you lose in the playoffs and you know
there are pitching decisions that that
don't go well and certainly in the last
game of nlcs when you've got your top
left-handed reliever warming up in the
bullpen and eddie rosario and freddie
freeman are set to bat for atlanta
left-handed batters
maybe you want to go to that guy before
you know rosario can hit the
game-winning home run um but in the
grand scheme the dodger pitching in the
playoffs had to do with how they juggled
max scherzer and julio orios and walker
bueller given that those were the only
healthy starting pitchers and so the
dodgers played with openers they played
with bullpen games they used urea
sinchurzer in relief
those decisions backfired and at least
with the dodgers those decisions are not
made at the dave roberts level those
decisions are made at the collaborative
level and as dave roberts himself said
during the playoffs from the tippy top
of the organization
albert pujol stunned
that's hard because he has really said
look guys let me get to the end of the
season and then i'll figure it out then
and he was not available the other night
after the dodgers lost her last game um
he's not an everyday player there's no
chance of that he can hit left-handers
okay
you're probably using him as a platoon
dh in a best-case scenario so i think
the first thing we have to figure is
is the national league going to have a
dh next year because we don't know the
collective bargaining agreement hasn't
come up there's been a lot of talk that
the universal dh will be implemented but
maybe not you know one of the other
things that's come up is this idea of a
double hook rule maybe everybody gets
the dh but you only get to use the dh as
long as you're starting pitchers in the
game because baseball wants starting
pitchers to go in longer you know that
could play a role as well so i think
it's just too soon to say but if he can
find a team that
can maximize his skill set as the
dodgers did which is basically
uh platoon dh platoon first base and
left-handed
you know attacked vehicle off the bench
then then he might have a shot
did you mention that corey seeger may
get 300 million dollars
i did and i think he will or at least
that will be the asking price asking
prices as we all know in free agency are
not necessarily contract prices but
if you're the agent for corey seeger a
fine gentleman by the name of scott
boris
and you see that francisco lindor signed
for
340 million dollars without even testing
the market and you think you've got a
premium shortstop and free agency a guy
you can play up the middle and still hit
for power
then i can't imagine you're going to
start debating much less than 300
million dollars
more impressive that the astros got to
the world series of the braves
i think the braves i mean the astros for
all their villainy and all their black
status throughout the rest of america
still a damn good team they were a damn
good team when they cheated to win they
are now a damn good team when presumably
they are not cheating to win but if you
looked at the braves they were
sputtering around 500 most of the year
and i really give alex anthopolis their
general manager and their ownership a
lot of credit because
it's pretty easy in this day and age to
tell fans
you know what this isn't our year let's
go get some prospects
and we'll be better next year and what
the braves did is say
you know we lost ronald the cuny junior
maybe the best player in the national
league we lost an entire starting
outfield
let's go get some players you know the
national league was out there to be
taken and if you looked at playoff odds
on the analytic websites didn't look
like a good thing for the braves to do
but guys were out there to get if the
braves would just take on a little cash
and they did and
maybe it doesn't work most of the time
but it did now and as a fan that's what
you want us to have some hope and faith
and the braves fans got some hope and
faith this year and as a result they're
back in the world series for the first
time since 1999. i usually hear from the
astros uh
because they got to the world series and
then i'll hear from the fans saying you
know what are you going to say about the
astros now
and my point is always the same
you had the talent to get to the world
series to win a world series
why would you jeopardize
that
pursuit that route by cheating a couple
of years ago
and
you know it for some reason it's like
hey we proved that we didn't cheat
somehow because we got to the world
series again
yeah i don't think this is some sort of
absolution for 2017
and i'm sure
if the dodgers had beaten the braves and
this world series was starting at dodger
stadium tomorrow
i don't think the fans at dodger stadium
would be holding up signs saying we
absolve you
it's still a sore spot for many people
here in los angeles and i'm sure around
the country and as the astros themselves
know from traveling the country for for
a lot of fans
but you know they're here and so we took
their caps to what they did this year
bill thank you and uh we appreciate your
time
all right take care that's uh bill
shaiken la times national baseball
writer covering the dodgers